- [Instructor] In this video,
we're going to try to
compute 6742 times 23.
So like always, pause this video and try
to compute it for yourself.
All right, now let's
work on this together.
And I'm going to do it
using what's often known
as the standard algorithm.
Algorithm is just a fancy
word for a series of steps,
a process for doing something.
So we have 6742 times 23.
And so I'm gonna write the 23
in the same place values.
So that's two 10s, so I'm gonna write it
under the four 10s over there.
And then three ones.
I'll write it under the two ones.
And it's important to realize
this isn't the only way
to multiply numbers.
In fact, we've studied
other methods for doing it
in other videos.
And it's important to realize
what's really going on
and how these different methods are all,
on some level, doing the same thing,
maybe just writing them different
or doing them in different orders.
So the way that we would tackle it using
the standard algorithm,
probably the way that your
parents first learned to multiply
multi-digit numbers like this
is we'll take all of the numbers in 6742,
all of the various places,
and multiply it by three.
And then we're gonna
multiply it times two 10s.
And then we're gonna add everything up.
So let's first multiply it times three.
So we have two times three, that is six.
Then we have four times three.
And what people often say is,
"Four times three is 12, write the two,
"and then carry the one."
But what really just happened is you said
four 10s times three is 12 10s.
12 10s can be written as two 10s plus 100.
Then we say seven times three is 21.
And then you'll say, "Oh, I
have to add that other one,
"so I get 22."
But once again, what just happened?
We said seven hundreds times three is 2100
plus another hundred is 22 hundreds,
which can be expressed as two hundreds
and two thousands.
And then, last but not
least, six times three is 18
plus two is 20.
But remember, we're
talking about thousands.
So this is 20 thousands.
So then we will move on to
the two 10s right over here.
So two times two 10s is four 10s.
Now some folks might be tempted to put
the four over there,
but that's not four 10s.
Four 10s would be right over here.
And so it's common practice as you move
to the next place value
over, as you get to this two,
that people will just put a zero here
just so they don't make that mistake.
All right, now let's keep going.
What is four times two?
Well that's eight.
We'll just write the
eight right over there.
Why did that work?
Well we're having four 10s times two 10s,
well that's going to be
eight times 10 times 10, eight hundreds.
And then we say what is seven times two.
That is 14, which of course we can write
the four and then we can
carry the one, so to speak.
And I'll cross these out
so I don't get confused.
And then six times two is
going to be equal to 12,
plus this one that we had carried, is 13.
So there we go.
And then we just have
to add everything up.
And we are going to get
six plus zero ones is six.
Two 10s plus four 10s is six 10s.
Two hundreds plus eight
hundreds is 10 hundreds,
which you could do as zero
hundreds and one thousand.
One thousand plus zero
thousands plus four thousands
is five thousands.
Two 10 thousands plus three 10 thousands
is going to be five 10 thousands.
And then we just have one hundred thousand
right over there.
So we've got 155,066.
And we are done.